hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Sunday those of you who were
able and had the time probably enjoyed
the great chess spectacle yesterday I'm
of course not referring to my own stream
even though I would like to thank
everyone for coming I was an amazing
experience and there were over 370
players playing in the tournament so you
know that's that's a huge tournament the
the biggest one yet and I would like to
thank Yann for joining me in the stream
and making you know making it a lot more
entertaining for everyone as I saw that
many of you really enjoy when young
joins the stream so I'll make sure to
invite him more often but what I am
referring to is the speech Chess
Championship organized by chess comm
featuring a match between Magnus Carlsen
and Wesley so it was you know as usual
quite an amazing experience watching
Carlsen give a good beating - everyone
in lower time formats I mean Wesley soul
is a top-10 player and he was I don't
know if he's still above 2800 but he was
for a long time you know he had that
unbelievable unbeaten streak of I
believe 56 or 57 games something below
60 before he was that game tomorrow but
he definitely shows that you know he is
a force to be reckoned with and
definitely one of the candidates to
maybe challenge Carlsen in the future
but in overtime formats it seems not to
be the case as usual the match was
played with three sections so there was
a 5 + 2 second increment 3 + 2 second
increment and the bullet section not a
real bullet but a 1 + 1 second increment
bullet and if Carlsen won the match with
a result of twenty seven and a half to
nine and a half which is which is
definitely a very nice result against
someone who is in the top 10 chess
players in the world he won the 5 + new
section with a result of 11 to 3 and he
won the bullet section with an amazing
12 and a half zero and a half so in the
both section Wesley so only managed to
get one draw but ok Wesley did win the 3
+ 2 section so not not that
it's a big of a disaster you know it's
it's not as bad as what Carson did ding
leerin a couple of days ago in the
champions showdown this is one game I
decided to show you it's from the
beginning of the match it's the five
plus two second increments section
Wester so has the white pieces and he
plays Knight to f3
Carson goes east 6 and we have c4 so we
have the English opening b6 g3 in Bishop
to b7 Bishop to G 2 G 6 so castles
Bishop to g7 Knight to c3 Knight to f6
we have d4 nice to e4 by Carlson and
Bishop to d2 here Carlson castles this
might seem like like a very good
opportunity to snatch this Bishop on d2
and you know rub white of the bishop
pair but capturing and e2 i only develop
the White Queen and well we still have
to cast laughter you Castle for example
White has this immediate efore and White
has a White has a perfect perfectly good
game you know rotate to d1 rook everyone
are coming and it's a very easy position
to play for for such a strong
Grandmaster so after Bishop too deep to
Carson castled and rook the C 1 C 5 we
have d5e captures C captures and calls
in place now Knight captures on d2 now
grabbing the Bishop Knight captures on D
2 and D 6/9 to c4 although maybe a
better plan for white here would be
something like a for the stops any
future ideas of a 6 and B 5 also now if
white is if black does push a 5 then
Knight to c4 comes with a threat of not
the with a threat but too threatening b6
and the d6 pawn so maybe a 4 was better
here but okaywe still played Knight to
c4 and this allows Carlsen to kind of
revive his Bishop on b7 as this d5 phone
is blocking it now he plays Bishop to a6
now attacking the knight on c4
b3 b5 kicking the night away
Knight to d2 Knight to d7 preparing
moves like Knight to e5 and it's
interesting that this actually stops the
idea of efore although voice they would
definitely enjoy pushing efore at some
point but in this position it's still
impossible because of a tactic Bishop
captures on c3 rook captures in c3 and
me for attacking both rooks Wesley is
losing the exchange here so after Knight
d7 were still played a four we have b4
Knight goes to e4 and Knight to e5 now
and still so far Carlson is very
successful in stopping Wesley from
pushing efore Knight to c4 was played
here you can to play a move like f4 even
though you know at some point you would
like to play rook e1 at 44 but f4
immediately to kick away the night is
very uncomfortable for white after a
night g4 move threatening nights to e3
at attacking the Queen and the rook you
can't really apply Queen c2 or because
you know 93 still attacks the Queen and
the rook
so after something like Queen to e1 then
Bishop to d4 check King H one night will
come T 3 and after rook to f3 only place
where the rook is temporarily safe rook
e8 and this is just I'm very very hard
to play for white all of his pieces are
tramped in and it's probably a winning
position for black swearin 95 voiceless
Knight to c4 but now he across in plays
Knight captures on c4 b captors on c4
and rook to e8 and now Carlson has a
bishop pair and this very strong past be
pawn this will be very hard to stop you
know in the hands of the world champion
this is this is a winning position for
black rook to e1 f5 now kicking the
knight back Knights to d2 and cross in
place Bishop to c3
now pinning the night and again not
allowing Wesley to push efore
III Queen to f6 Rock to e2
unpinning the night so the night can
unpin rook to e7 Carson is preparing to
double up on the e-file Queen to b3 rook
a to e8 a now Carson does double up
night the b1 attacking the bishop cousin
of course mu not trade this very strong
Bishop Carson plays Bishop to e5
now with ideas of g5 + f4 this is very
unpleasant for Wesley the rook an e2 is
undefended Carson is ready to break open
the Kings side so Wesley plays F for
himself he stops this idea but he allows
another idea Carson plays Bishop to d4
and this move in itself is already
winning the pawn on e3 and the game the
best move here is something like king -
h1 but again you're losing that pawn and
you're losing the game really really bad
but where's the plate rook to e1 and it
took a course in less than a second to
play his next move Carlson plays the
immediate Bishop captures on e3 with
check again King - h1 probably a safer
way to go but you're losing this game
with the played King captures on e3
sorry rook captures on e3 and after rook
captures and e3 rook captures and e3
Queen to d4 now pinning the rook the
nada Queen and the rook are attacking
this rook and in this position Wesley
resigned the game because you can't
protect the rope if you play King f2 you
get Bishop to c4 and now you lose the
Queen on b3 you can't go to a 3 you can
go to c3 you can go to d3 and there is
no square the White Queen can go to
still protect the rock on e3 if you move
the Queen for example Queen c2
Queen captures and e3 is checkmate so
obviously would have to give up the
Queen if he played this line with King
f2 but he didn't after Queen to d4 he
resigned the game so yeah a beautiful
victory by a world champion Magnus
Carlsen it's only only 29 moves so
definitely quite an achievement we
the black pieces you know a very
enjoyable thing to watch how magnus
carlsen can prevent top ten chess player
in the world from pushing g4 you know
with white it's a you know very very
enjoyable so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Thomas Cochrane and Paul first for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
once again thank you everyone for
joining the stream I do hope you can
make it as usual I'm very sorry I made
the stream at the same time Wesley so
versus Magnus Carlsen was going on but I
announced it before I even saw that the
time that this match was going on so
sorry about that
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon